that's why I put Post-it notes because
because sometimes when I'm traveling
like Nikki's like hey I can't fit my
tampons so can you put them in your back
but then I don't want the TSA guys to
think I'm like a [__] yeah so then I
put like a posting on and it's like hey
These are not my these are my wife's
tampon so then when they open my bag
then they're like oh okay this guy's
yeah he's not a little
[Music]
you ever played a little too rough with
your partner to which they were uh
suffering an injury no because I use
safe words thank you what's the safe
word what do you mean play like you say
basketball my head daddy is that safe
word yeah that's a safe word kind of
literal like you know if you're just
messing around horse play I don't know
just like getting wild I sound like an
old man
horse play horse play a little rough
houses oh sometimes sometimes uh
when we're on the couch I'll lean on my
girl's hair and then she'll flip the
[__] out that's a big one yeah and I'm
like what do you mean you lean on her
hair like I'll like I'll get up off the
couch and she's laying down and then
I'll like I'll push on it yeah and her
head's on the on the couch and then I
push on her hair and then she's like ah
she can't take it she's what the [__]
what do you mean by that well I don't
know I'm just trying to but you don't
know about that yeah bro you never bit
you never cuddled up oh Geo kind of got
short hair though or Jill's also like
over here so maybe she's stepping on my
hand
I think she does on my hair
I know what that feels yeah it hurts
because you're like
at the same way yeah
um one time Tiff was I was showing Tiff
the taser I bought for her that she's
never used or she never keeps with her
at all and she was doing
um what's that thing called where you
curl your eyelashes eyelash curler and
you tased her nah I just was I was like
babe look and then she was doing it as
she did it and she like she was like oh
[__] is she she she like pulled some
eyelashes out oh with a taser no no she
was doing it and I was showing it and
you know the pop yeah
she jumped and she pulled around yeah
yeah
oh my god oh no yes wow dude but that
was about it Nick one time I punched in
the face because she was talking back to
me let's go we got a situation here
where a couple
was having a little you know this couple
was drinking yeah having some fun
messing around and they razzled they
didn't wrestle but one of them ended up
uh they decided to play hide and seek
the dude uh ends up hiding in a suitcase
that's that's what he gets no whatever
happens dude that's a good place a guy
can fit in a suitcase yeah I did that
must be a really big one or they're just
a really small guy it's a big suitcase
he's not a little guy he's not a big
suitcase he's in there he's not a Circus
Olay guy um and then somehow he gets
stuck in the suitcase and then the girl
uh gets so drunk that she falls asleep
no does he lose oh no there's buddy live
I know he died oh what no here's a
picture of him
did you pull that out from Google I
thought he got stuck in a Pelican case
or something what the [__] like you
can't stick your finger through the
zipper or like rip through I think even
then you're not gonna get enough air
after that thing you could
fight and someone would smell it on the
outside they're playing hide and seek
and he zips up he can't unzip it
no way man my guy first time I didn't
feel sorry for someone I for sure
thought it was like a Pelican case where
it latches yeah
looking at this do you see any hints oh
no the eyes the eyes
she looks like
this is
she suffocated with the pillow first and
then stuffed his ass inside apparently
how did she fit her weird stuff
he decided to hide in this [__]
suitcase that is completely breathable
that's what I'm saying there's no way my
guy gets in the suitcase and then he's
like oh I got such a good spot
[Laughter]
and also who the [__] is playing hide
and seek when you're drunk when you're
[__] 33 and [__] yeah dude she looks
like she's 45 years old so uh what
happens is that is the initial report is
that she goes she's actually the one who
I think called the cops oh really and
then they came and then they're like I
want to hear the the call I wonder we
don't have the call but what happens is
they uh they pull up the call just
Google can you just AI the call or
something can you just like create one
[__] it can you pull up the transcribe
what the [__] man this is why I just
make up with the goals here hang on this
is why we keep losing followers
best I can do is show you a phone that's
for sale okay 44. that's a good one
uh so what happens is because because uh
they're sensing like a slight suspicion
about it so they ask her like hey would
you consent to a search of your phone
in which they look through her phone and
just right there right there is a video
of her recording the suitcase with him
pleading to be let out and her saying
that's on you this is what I feel like
when you cheat on me you should probably
shut the [__] up because he's saying I
can't breathe she recorded that she
recorded it so he really couldn't get
out of a regular suitcase but he
couldn't get out wait so he wait did she
put him in there that's like the last
thing I would say it's unclear if well I
don't think she put him in there I think
something led to him going into it and
then she locked it or zipped it up and
he couldn't get out and then do you
think that Panic caused an expedited
death dude probably him just like
probably I mean because you're if you're
hypervised phobic or something you know
right because um and you realize she's
like doing this at a spite sometimes I
open my packet as a suitcase and then
there's that TSA strip like we looked in
your bag you ever get that [__] yeah and
I'm all like how yeah
like I had it zipped up and locked yeah
well they can just open the lock yeah
the TSA approved block
that they have ability to unlock it
anytime they see fit yeah well they
re-locked it for me that's why I put
post-nuts because because sometimes when
I'm traveling like Nikki's like hey I
can't fit my tampon so can you put them
in your back but then I don't want the
TSA guys to think I'm like a [__] yeah
so then I put like a posting on and it's
like hey These are not my dude these are
my wife's tampon so then when they open
my bag then they're like oh okay this
guy's yeah he's not a little [__]
so in their inner phone not even in a
hidden folder good to know that every
time they check my bag they think I'm a
[__] oh yeah well no you're you're a
girl how would they know if I'm at the
grocery store and I'm buying tampons I'm
always like hey everybody in line I'm
just getting this from my wife
[Laughter]
to make sure that they know that yeah
hey I thought you were gay and I'm like
the season yeah well these days men can
menstruate too so it could be for you
these days weren't they always able to
no no now you can buy pizza sauce and
you can throw it in just like you know
or whatever
there's guys out there fighting for the
right to get tampons in the bathroom so
they could menstruate that's pretty cool
yeah and Colleen just said
solidarity
the solidarity side it was good all
right so yeah the uh looking into this
couple there's like a whole slew of
records of different times that they
have been in domestic violence with each
other and other partners so they've had
lots of [__] problems the funny thing
is the cops when they find the video
they're like uh what they ask her like
why do you have that in there and she
goes I don't remember recording the
videos I admit it looks bad
oh my God
it's not what it looks like and that's
why they let her go
not only that they released her into
Knott's Berry Farm have fun tonight
here's a 500 credit have fun go crazy we
believe you so yeah she's arrested and
uh
it sucks as in that that dude that died
he has three kids and uh and the girl
has a son separate from that so they're
leaving a lot of kids without parents
bro some of these girls will get you
killed out here man do you put them in a
coffin or just have the suitcase that's
appeared
well he's already in there is it open to
suitcase or clothes
God that's pretty funny Jesus Christ
just lower the bag
I found the metal on the back
oh my God why'd you say that dick
I don't know what I was thinking man
that's why fart is toxic it's later in
the day I'm a little delirious dude all
that aspartame dude
it's making my brains go crazy
I can't even think of it I'm embarrassed
I don't even think no way they actually
have the thing on here
that's how she called in my boyfriend is
dead yeah
I fell asleep and I woke up and he was
dead in the suitcase I don't know what
happened
number three
coming out of his mouth
yeah Jesus bro dude the way she called
that in the sound of a cold lie that
just makes it so real that's so crazy
she's like my boyfriend's dead [__] it's
almost not funny but
here we are laughing but Bart had the
line of the day
[Music]
foreign